hey guys you know that males and females
are different i mean physically
different and so in this video i'm gonna
show you eight very interesting things
about the male body you probably didn't
know this is gonna be an interesting one
so let's get to it
[Music]
all right now let's get into the lists
and before we do just test yourself see
if you already knew anything that's on
my list
your skin is thicker than a woman's yeah
it's thicker because of the amount of
testosterone that's going through your
body your skin is around 25
thicker than a woman's skin now it's
interesting that it's not just thicker
but it's also tougher yeah your skin is
tough tougher than a woman's skin but as
you grow older you get less testosterone
right your body produces less
testosterone when you age so that means
your skin will also get thinner
you gain muscle faster
now this is also because of your
testosterone i'm not saying that women
cannot gain muscle of course we know
they do i mean there are a lot of women
out there that's doing bodybuilding but
men will gain muscle faster
you can experience a type of pms
now we know when we don't get periods we
don't get pms but we can experience
hormonal changes as well and that can
make you more irritable tired and you
can get stomach cramps as well
men age slower than women
let me explain this one as we age we
lose our collagen levels slower than
women so we don't physically age slower
we just look like we do because of the
elasticity in our skin
milk
now this is a bit of a crazy one but
yeah men you can produce milk because of
your glands through your chest now
before you go crazy as i did when i
first heard this let me just explain
this
if you do produce milk it shows you that
something is wrong with your body and it
happens when too much prolactin is
produced that is a certain hormone and
this might also happen with certain
medical treatments
the adam's apple
you know women they don't have one right
i'm kidding of course they do have one
yours is just bigger so why is it bigger
well when your body goes through changes
when you go from being a boy to a man
you get a bigger voice box that's why
you can speak in deeper tones all it is
is basically a piece of bony cartilage
that sits on the top of the thyroid
gland
boldness
how many men do you know that's bold
alright now how many women do you know
that's bald not a lot right yeah it's
something has got to do with us men and
he's mostly got to do with your genes
so take a look at your family at your
father's parents and your mother's
parents if some of them are bold chances
are you might be bold as well or if
you're not bold yet you might become
bold when you get older it's a real
thing it happens mostly between
20 and 30 and then in your mid-30s you
can definitely start to really see it
again this also depends on your genes
some men they go bold quicker than
others now be careful because if you
don't eat healthy if you don't have a
healthy lifestyle and if you have a poor
diet all of these things can make that
you go bold a lot faster
guys usually are warmer than women
this is all because of your muscles yes
your muscle mass you then have a lower
resting body temperature which of course
keeps you a little bit warmer now if you
want to know how to increase your
testosterone or your sperm count watch
these videos here and i'll see you there
and before you go remember
always life is short so don't waste
yours cheers guys